coming up next week cyber security
piracy in africa ttip and ukraine
welcome to the agenda
with north korea really behind the hack
on sony and it did a security for later
apple's icloud getting hacked by china
as cyber attacks become all the more
sophisticated europe is trying to find
ways to best protect itself a
pan-european cyber security directive is
in the pipeline but has had a tepid
response in some member states because
it would drive up costs
google apple and facebook big companies
opposing it all eyes on the director of
the european network and information
security agency as he pops into the
parliament on monday
over to another kind of pirate and no i
don't mean jack sparrow in pirates of
the caribbean some years back the choppy
waters of the somalian coast were a
piracy hotbed with daily attacks as the
waters there have stilled western africa
has now been passed the poison chalice
with countries looking again to europe
for help a discussion is set for tuesday
at a meeting of the security and defence
committee
bringing ukraine closer to europe and
from the clutches of russian dominance
it's got a whole lot more expensive the
eu is set to step up its assistance to
the fallen country to the tune of 1.8
billion euros the aim is to boost the
economy while strengthening democracy
and rule of law on thursday the
international trade committee will vote
on the package
displaced vulnerable and destitute in
lebanon tents pepper some of its poorest
neighborhoods
over a million stateless syrians now
call lebanon home
with the country stretched how can the
international community best respond the
un representative for lebanon highlights
the plights of refugees on tuesday
as a group of meps hops across the pond
to washington dc over at the parliament
a debate with the trade commissioner
cecilia malstrom on the controversial
u.s trade deal
will there be any bending of the will on
the investor state dispute settlement
mechanism that gives wide powers to
corporations follow that debate on
wednesday
and finally a band of meps are in
armenia on monday for the latest uranus
inter-parliamentary meeting and don't
forget ecoal the in-car emergency system
that dials that when you get into an
accident goes to a final vote on
wednesday
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week
you